the S&L crisis some people say well it's
going to bring down the whole US economy
all by itself and if it doesn't by
itself it will with other problems with
the banking industry and the Great debt
which corporations and individuals have
in this country we're going to find out
the latest status of the S&L crisis and
what's been happening with Rob Widdowson
who's one of the country's experts on it
we did a previous program in which Rob
told us a lot of the escapades some of
these crooks who have drained and
destroyed the SNL system we're going to
get an update the most recent thing I
heard was they're finally admitting
incrementally over the weeks well it
didn't go to cost so many billions it's
going to cost more billions the latest
thing is 500 billion but you see there's
a lot more than that don't you rock
well you're right Frank I think it is
going to cost us a lot more and you were
right to use the word incremental
essentially the Savings and Loan
industry has collapsed a most analysts
serious analysts feel that it's not
going to survive this crisis and it
would have collapsed quickly if the
entire truth had been told when it
happened but the government was afraid
that there would be another immediate
Great Depression with a collapse of the
banking system and so the system has
been propped up and it will disappear
slowly over several years during which
time we will slide into a depression in
this country how much you think it's
going to cost the taxpayers altogether
what are your what's your projection at
least a trillion probably more a
trillion al that's a 500 billion dollar
difference between what the government
is admitting now and what you're saying
what is the X where's the extra 500
billion coming from well I mean you've
got to go back to the original bailout
bill which in which taxpayers were
supposed to pay 50 billion dollars for
300 SNL's which we're going to be
and over now two weeks after the bailout
bill was passed the Bush administration
was saying that it was inadequate one of
the reasons is that part of the bailout
bill is that the requirements capital
requirements for the savings and loans
have increased the capital requirement
is that the amount of money that's left
over after a bank pays off all its
depositors and pulls in all of its loans
so in other words theoretically that
could happen on any given day and so a
bank has to have a surplus for safe
operation and that surplus is called the
capital requirement it was one and a
half percent of total deposits for
savings and loans banks during the
deregulation era part of the bailout
bill is to increase the capital
requirement in two steps now the first
step was January 1st 1990 because of
that an extra an additional 400 savings
and loans are going to go down they
can't meet those requirements they don't
have enough capital reserve so that's
why the numbers are changing okay now
what they're not telling us is that the
capital requirements are going to double
again in 1992 to 6% and again most
serious analysts feel that at least
two-thirds of the SNL's in this country
will not be able to meet those
requirements which means 1,800 SNL's are
going to fail and that means the
government will take those over and
assume all those bad that's all of that
all tanta or they'll have to come up
with something more creative because
that's going to happen doesn't seem to
be any question
so the original bailout bill was fifty
billion dollars and the number with
interest on the loans the usual number
used is a hundred and sixty six billion
dollars total cost but that's only the
first ten years of interest payments the
the loans the fifty billion dollar loan
is being made with 30-year bonds so that
means the interest will spread over
actually 30 years and the actual cost of
fifty billion dollars is in the realm of
two hundred and twenty five billion over
30 years the number that's usually used
is one hundred and sixty six billion
which is the first ten years after the
crisis now even using that number 166
billion the original bailout bill
estimated that three hundred SNL's would
cost that now with the new capital
requirements in 1992 eighteen hundred
will go down that's six times what was
originally projected and six times 166
billion is it trillion now doesn't it
it's amazing to me that six percent
capital requirement doesn't seem
unreasonable that they seem like they
should any any bank would have their
hands on six percent you know for cash
good well that's the infected standard
for commercial banks but you got to
remember if you're talking about a
billion dollar six percent of a billion
dollars is a lot of cash to have on hand
that's a lot of money the other problem
is that the Savings and Loan industry
during deregulation was at one and a
half percent and you know many of these
banks were in trouble right now and so
for them to pull in you know hundreds of
millions of dollars in some cases I say
it's just just too much why has it taken
so long for the Bush administration to
take action and get something going on
this
I mean this is an enormous enormous
plotting a devastating economic crisis
so that we're in and yet they're just
dawdling along and not doing anything
much about it well now we you bring up a
point that bears on the Resolution Trust
Corporation okay remember that the
bailout bill established the Resolution
Trust Corporation a semi federal agency
that was off budget so that they
wouldn't have to worry so much about
gramm-rudman the budgetary limitations
so that fifty billion dollars that they
borrowed twenty billion they borrowed
from the Treasury so it's on budget but
thirty billion dollars they decided to
borrow off budget that is to say it
wouldn't be listed in the u.s. deficit
so they could meet gramm-rudman that
they were they able to sell those bonds
as easily as the Treasury bond well they
had to offer them a little high and a
little higher interest rate because they
were directly from the Treasury that
alone is going to cost about five
billion that extra quarter percent in
interest that was the first purpose of
the Resolution Trust Corporation the
second purpose was to have a place to
put all the assets that were seized from
failed and failing savings and loans so
the Resolution Trust Corporation now
owns all of the bad assets including the
bad mortgages the bad loans the anything
that was given in collateral on those
loans which is right now about four
hundred billion dollars worth of assets
of half of it is real estate the problem
is that 40% of that real estate 25 to
40% it's hard to tell right now is raw
land with no economic value whatsoever
35 percent of those assets are tied up
in litigation is no clear title yet
nobody knows who owns it okay
it's just a disaster they don't even
have a clear catalogue to what they have
in the Resolution Trust Corporation all
of these properties this is just a
disaster all of these properties taxes
have to be paid on them they have to be
maintained in some cases there are
vandalized office buildings and
apartment buildings the carrying costs
for the assets of the Resolution Trust
the government's estimate so it's bound
to below is 25 to 40 percent annually
which amounts to how much well if we've
got 400 billion now 25 percent would be
100 billion a year to carry those assets
now this is part of the one trillion
that you know that's not even in there
oh my god now the government is in a
real hard place there's enormous
carrying costs are building up and
building up and building up and so it's
to all of our best interests for them to
dispose of these assets as quickly as
possible of course however if they do
the enormity of the assets is such that
the bottom will drop out of the real
estate market it already is
unfortunately the rest of the banking
system is badly overextended in real
estate loans and so if the Resolution
Trust dumps all that property into the
market then all the banks in the country
will fail and we'll have a depression
but if they don't sell this stuff then
the that's right they will keep running
exact taxpayers or as Harry gave us
enormous carrying costs at the first of
the year George Bush submitted his first
budget and in that budget he asked for a
hundred billion dollars extra
okay in a working capital they called it
for the Resolution Trust Corporation
closed down Morrison Ellis answered pay
those carrying costs those carrying
costs go to whom well of their taxes are
paid to the government property managers
real estate of people appraisers lawyers
I mean it's an incredible boon for them
in fact there in fact there are groups
of important investors who have gotten
together and established companies to
manage property national companies to
manage property of course didn't make a
fortune
are these some of the same scumbags who
ran the SNL's into the ground start out
with they might be an Israeli friends
but anyway that's the problem it's a
rock and hard place
the meter is running it's enormous
enormous carrying costs it was just
announced that the Treasury Department
gave the Resolution Trust permission to
borrow forty five billion dollars this
quarter directly from the Treasury
off-budget again I and well nobody knows
about the budget they haven't decided
yet although it's a if it is on budget
it means that gramm-rudman has already
been exceeded six months into the year
but there is a an escape clause in Grand
Redman that says that money borrowed
after a certain point during the fiscal
year will not go on budget so I think
they've waited until that point so but
anyway they you know every quarter
they're going to come back and just get
permission from the Treasury there's no
oversight Congress isn't involved it's
just directly drawn out now they say
they're going to pay it back with the
sale of assets out of the Resolution
Trust but I mean even their rosiest
projections is that you know not twenty
or thirty percent that's going to be
covered
now why didn't they take quick action to
start out with Oh was there another
factor other other than that they would
depress the real-estate market there
certainly was this whole disaster is
based in well there's only one way to
say at a conspiracy
I'm a conspiracy of really unbelievable
portions and it began back at the
beginning of the savings and loan crisis
when the bank's got deregulated
savings-and-loan industry was on the
ropes anyway during the 70s because of
inflationary pressures interest rates
were allowed to float and what that
meant was that the savings and loans who
were limited to the amount that they
could offer in deposits interest on
deposits were getting beaten badly
because people were taking their money
out SNL's and go into places that could
offer higher rights so those interest
rate caps were taken off and the S&L
started to compete with big banks for
big bucks but they were still limited to
mortgages basically and so in 1982 there
was the guard San Germaine deregulation
act that said they could do anything
they can invest directly in real estate
they could car loans credit cards they
could do it all
and so now they were big money was
coming into them and now they could do
what they wanted with it unfortunately
in that deregulation bill they left in
the insurance part so that there was no
risk for these bankers insuring all
accounts up to a hundred thousand right
exactly and that's where all the money
was coming from
my name is coming from broker deposits
which is where corporations are wealthy
folks give a lot of money for example if
you had a million
dollars you'd give it to a broker who
would then break it up into ten $100,000
chunks to meet the insurance limit and
then deposited in ten different savings
and loans around the country that we're
offering the highest interest rates so a
billions poured in I mean they double
triple quadruple their assets in a year
many of them all around the country one
went from 11 million to 792 million in
assets in 18 months I mean it was
ridiculous
so they I mean they were having fun that
all this money was pouring in now some
of them started to get overextended and
started to fail and the when they failed
the insurance fund of the Savings & Loan
industry had to pay off those deposits
FSL IC f SLIC fizzling the Federal
Savings & Loan Insurance Corporation and
the way the Charter read was that the
Savings and Loan industry when you
bought in and you bought a piece of the
Insurance Corporation and you paid in a
certain amount based on the deposits
that you had in your bank every year and
so it built up to five billion dollars
or so and that's what was used to bail
out these banks to pay off the
depositors now it was the responsibility
of the Savings & Loan industry to take
care of itself to insure those deposits
although the federal government said in
the Charter backed with the Full Faith
and Credit of the United States Treasury
and that was their big mistake because
in the 80s after deregulation when the
banks started to fail the rest of the
industry got together and they said
wait a minute we're in trouble because
our insurance fund is going to get
depleted here pretty soon and we're
responsible for paying off all those
deposits so what are we going to do
because we don't want to pay off that
money so what they decided to do was to
keep the extent of the losses secret
until so much money had hemorrhaged out
that they didn't have enough to pay off
and the only recourse was to have the
taxpayers pick up the bill The Full
Faith and Credit of the United States
Treasury so their plan was to let the
losses get so bad that they would have
to go to the government and say look if
we try and pay this off there's going to
be a crash a collapse of our banking
system and the country will go into a
depression so you have to bail it out
was this in collusion with the executive
branch of the government and Congress
well who knows who knows however in
testimony in 1985 before congressional
committee Edwin gray who was the head
head bank examiner nationally the head
of the Bank board he testified that the
u.s. League of saving institutions which
is the head lobby group of the savings
and loans told him not once but on
several occasions that the overriding
strategy of the Savings & Loan industry
was to buy time to buy time and to buy
time until only the taxpayer could bail
it out and he said that in front of
Congress in 1985 well it seems to be
borne out also by the fact that the Bush
administration Donald and fiddled around
and didn't take any action didn't even a
you know appoint the people they were
supposed to appoint to run this thing
and so they strung it out so this fix in
this fits into the conspiratorial part
that you talk now of course the loss has
happened pretty fast a lot faster I
think then the savings loan industry
expected although they their strategy
was to hold out if they could hold out
the full extent of the losses until
after the 90 1988 presidential elections
say they felt that then they could go to
the government and say that was it
so they had to hold out till then and
also it would embarrass the Bush
campaign experiment it yeah exactly well
it's interesting you bring that up
because in 1987 gentlemen named Danny
wall replaced Edwin gray as the head
regulator and Danny wall was a good
friend of the Savings and Loan industry
he had in fact written the garden center
Maine deregulation Act of 1982 when he
was on the staff of Jake Gardens on Jake
Garn staff so he was one of the insiders
one of the buddies so it was a closed
circle oh yeah he had the regulator was
the big buddy with Congress and with the
banking industry itself sure S&L sure
yeah he was a good friend of theirs he
met with some of the real famous
notorious SNL owners keying met with
wall seven times this first three months
and let's talk he seems to be the
number-one villain and the scumbag in
this whole outfit it's unbelievable what
you've got a good good yarn to spend
about Keating too who were Michael
Charles Keating - Charles Charles
Keating okay well I mean this guy he was
one regular said he was the worst of the
worst and the Keating story is a litany
of fraud abuse bribery it's astounding
what this guy did he started in in
Cincinnati was working for another
company and he made him a lot of money
but in the late 70s the Securities and
Exchange Commission started to
investigate but the company particularly
Keating for loaning company funds to his
family
so Keating decided to leave Cincinnati
he went to Phoenix where he bought a
company called American continental
corporation ACC it was a real estate
company and Keating began to dabble in
real estate and one Phoenix official
politician said that everything changed
when Keating hit town
he started handing out money left and
right in a few years a few years he was
he was donating $100,000 to each of
several City Council people Jes their
campaign that's a kind of local City
Council people are lost and would like
to have oh man I mean imagine if you
want a zoning change as a real estate
developer and you're paying a hundred
thousand bucks to the people in the City
Council with you know it's likely your
indicator real estate yeah anyway he
decided he wanted a savings and loan in
1984 he found Lincoln Savings and Loan
in Irvine California so he bought
Lincoln Savings and Loan and it may
became a subsidiary of AC C that's
important later on there's first three
investments were a hundred million
dollars that he gave to Ivan Boesky to
invest a hundred and twenty six million
dollars in junk bonds to finance a a
buyout attempt of Gulf Broadcasting
Corporation and 300 million dollars
direct real estate investment to build a
enormous lavish hotel in the desert
outside of Phoenix called the Phoenicia
which is where he lives he built himself
a palace
those were his first investments now
right around this time Gray who was at
the time the head examiner nationally
was worried about these risky
investments junk bonds and direct
investment in real estate developing and
so he decided to impose a rule 10% of
the assets of any Savings and Loan could
go to those kinds of risky investments
well Keating didn't like that I mean
he'd already in the first six months he
had 80%
of the assets in risky places my god
yeah
80% he by the way he bought Lincoln
Savings and Loan with 51 million dollars
that he borrowed from drexels office in
Beverly Hills where Mike Milligan Milken
lived were tied to Drexel Burnham
Lambert and milk and later was indicted
and when they've they've already gone
down head the company has gone up mhm
yeah and of course rawski Boesky was
convicted a few years ago yeah for fraud
insider trading and so forth and he did
all his work with Milken and drexel
burnham so I mean there's obvious
connections here anyway
so Keating went to work he decided that
he wanted an exemption from the 10% rule
so the first thing he did was he hired a
famous economist to look at his books he
paid alan greenspan alan greenspan he's
the head of the Federal Reserve yeah
okay wasn't then yeah okay they paid him
a hundred thousand dollars to look at
Lincoln's books
well he took a look and he said hey
they're great but gray just wouldn't
relent
he said no ten percent did so he too got
mad now this this started a battle
between Keating and gray that lasted
until gray was was thrown out by raises
a top regulator head of the Bank ball he
was the national head of the Bank board
and he actually was a an honest guy and
he tried to do something about this but
nobody would listen to him he said he
was a pariah you know he'd caught him
he'd make phone calls and he wouldn't
get any calls back you know anyway
Keating once bragged that he spent 11
million dollars trying to get rid of
gray he offered gray a job for $300,000
in his company great I turned him down
yeah I mean this guy okay so in 1985 a
vacancy opened up on the bank board to
the committee that gray presided over so
Keating called dawn Reagan who was a
chief of staff in Ron Reagan's white
house and got a friend of
his name's Lee Henkel placed on the
backboard Henkel load heating our
Lincoln Savings allowed a lot of money
okay so they got a mother bank board and
the very first thing he did was he
offered a proposal to exempt Lincoln
Savings and Loan from the 10% rule and
so the Department of Justice began to
investigate ankles connection to Keating
and key and so Henkel resigned from the
bank board now all this time the San
Francisco bank examiners were to start
to look at Lincoln's books and a couple
of things they noticed first of all they
noticed that there were several sham
transactions in the books where Lincoln
would have some real estate and would
make a loan to a company over here and
then that company would loan the money
to this company here which was done by
the real estate at a big profit for
Lincoln but Lincoln had loaned the money
in the first place so they bought it
back from themselves so trying to make
the books look good and I saw this big
piece of real estate for a big profit
the second thing they noticed was that
the office that they were given at
Lincoln Savings alone into which to work
to look at the books was bugged and so
every time they called the other the
main office and said hey we found
such-and-such when we found it they were
picking it up how did they figure that
out because the executives it's at
Lincoln seem to have this ESP about what
was going on
they were they were ahead of they had
all moves with a Fed covered before they
walked in the door exactly that's
happened so the San Francisco
recommended that Lincoln be examined
closely they didn't recommend that it be
closed yet that was later at the same
tell well all this was going on
Keating switched auditors now the
auditors are what you do if you're a big
corporation is you hire a company an
accounting firm to examine your books
and to rate them and that's for
investment purposes you can get people
to invest your money and money in your
company so Keating hired Arthur Young
accounting one of the big that table the
big a now that's had the top accounting
firms they've since merged houses big
seven yeah there's since merged but the
account was given to a guy named
Atchison who was vice president and mr.
Rogerson gave Keeley Lincoln's books a
clean bill of health all the way through
in fact he even stepped out of the usual
neutral role that auditors are supposed
to take when they examine the books and
voluntarily went before the bank board
to defend of Lincoln's accounting
practices and uh try and overturn the
10% rule my gosh
and of course he was turned down later
on by the way the government in a suit
looked at had an independent auditor
look at Lincoln's books at that time and
let me just tell you what the testimony
was they hired Kenneth Leventhal
corporation to examine Lincoln spokes
the firm's Roger Johnson testified that
Keating savings and loan had reported
135 million dollars in
tax gains on 15 land transactions
however and this is a direct quote there
was a net outflow of cash from Lincoln
in all 15 cases amounting to 217 million
so instead of 135 on the plus side they
had actually lost 217 million mm-hmm
seldom in our experience as accountants
have we encountered a more egregious
example of the misapplication of
generally accepted accounting principles
so Johnson Lincoln created profits by
making loans many of the loans were bad
Lincoln was manufacturing profits by
giving its money away while Keating
didn't care him it was all insured right
yeah well so this is the stuff that
Arthur young man said was okay oh yeah I
mean he went before the board and
defended it interestingly enough in 1988
mr. Atchison
from Arthur Young from Arthur Young had
to leave the firm somebody had made him
an offer he couldn't refuse that's right
he took a job with a CC Phoenix company
for $1,000,000 a year and that was the
accounting firm
yeah I feel the slime wasn't off my oh
wait just wait has the story as the
story goes on the numbers get bigger and
bigger and dollars unbelievable what
this guy did next right at that time
Edwin Gray was not reconfirmed in his
position as head of the Bank board by
the Congress instead Danny wall was put
in the old buddy in
assistant battles the guy the Jake Jake
Gardens friend who had written the guard
says oh they finally got their insider
buddy to be head of the Bank board
that's right and interestingly enough
just before Walt took office he met with
Katie Keaton gave a check for $100,000
for for the Garden Institute a think
tank conservative economic think tank
when wall took office in the first few
months he was there he met with Keating
seven times nobody knows what they
talked about the meetings were secret
but right just after that wall told
William Seidman of the FDIC in the hall
at the water fountain that he had the
Lincoln problem taken care of and there
was also an internal memo in the bank
board that said that the Lincoln case
was politically dangerous that any
discussion was to be kept private
non-public off the books off the record
and that of any problems with Lincoln
were to be referred directly to Danny
walk six months after he took office a
wall by this time the San Francisco bank
examiners had had recommended that
Lincoln be closed and so Keating was
really on the ropes and so he hired I
shouldn't say that
he called five senators forensic is to
whom he had donated money for their
campaigns to go and talk to those
regulators and try and straighten him
out and they did and they told the they
told those examiner's that they were
being mean to mr. Keating that he was
really a nice guy and he didn't deserve
that kind of treatment they should lay
off as this the famous five everyone
knows who that's the famous Keating five
the Keating five who were they they were
the two senators from Arizona McCain and
Dick and Cheney
senator Glenn John Glenn and then regal
Don regal who was head of the Banking
Committee in the Senate and Alan
Cranston Liberal Democrat from
California they all needed money they
were all broke campaign funds so by the
way uh you know the usual number is that
1.3 million dollars was donated to those
five total to those five people but
what's usually not mentioned is that
Senator McCain took several trips to
Bermuda and the Bahamas paid for by
Keating his wife and when that
information became public he paid it
back you know some 15,000 dollars or
something like that for the trips and
also more importantly Deacon Cheney's
top aides received fifty million dollars
in real estate loans from Lincoln
Savings and Loan so I mean it was
serious money
so the Senators took it upon themselves
to get together with San Francisco
examiner's but the examiners would not
relent they were mad at Keating I mean
he tried to he offered jobs to a couple
of people in the office and I mean he
was they're the real heroes in this
uh-huh
they just kept it winter who they are um
well I'm sorry past story is the name of
the head regular and his wife was a
lawyer in the office and Keating offered
her a job in any event the San Francisco
examiner's had recommended the bank be
closed because of the sham transactions
so a Danny wall moved the case to his
office where he could watch it
personally
and so he looked at those transactions
and he decided that they were not sham
at all that they were real transactions
and he said that they would be allowed
they overrode well they say the San
Francisco office kept hammering and kept
hammering and despite the Keating five
and despite all the tactics eventually
in early part of 1989 little over a year
ago January 1989 the Bank board finally
said that indeed those transactions some
of them were sham 124 million dollars
were sham now Lincoln was a subsidiary
of a CC member said this was a ruin and
the reason that Lake in one of these
profits on the books was so that they
could pay taxes that sounds weird they
wanted to pay taxes but those taxes went
to the parent company not directly to
the IRS so the subsidiary paid its taxes
to ACC and then ACC was supposed to put
the money in the IRS however however
ninety five million dollars was paid in
taxes from Lincoln to ACC from 1985 to
1988 end of 1988 and it disappeared it
never got to the IRS okay so here was
Keating's problem when they disallowed
124 million dollars in profits they also
said that he had to pay sixty million
dollars in taxes overpaid taxes back
from ACC to Lincoln and he didn't have
it it was really in trouble
well on April 1st Keating got word that
the regulator's were going to close
Lincoln okay now he was tipped off those
are these are supposed to be secret
okay but he was tipped off and it was
very expensive because what he did was
he sold all of the good assets out of
Lincoln to other subsidiaries of ACC and
then he declared bankruptcy for ACC put
it into Chapter 11 and he protected all
those assets he's kind of a genius in a
way I mean what did I don't know how
this guy was in the banking business I
mean he was in the sleaze business I
mean he must have spent all this time
doing these machination and some
manipulations but I mean it gets worse
and worse he declared bankruptcy and so
out of the closet came all of these a
middle income low income people who had
bonds from ACC yeah they bought into the
company they hadn't people who hadn't
didn't have CDs or deposits but actually
had bonds that they bought it of accd
yeah but but they had bought them at
Lincoln thinking that they were CDs
insured a licensure dawns they weren't
then though it was a scam it was an
illegal scam it was fraud well Keating
paid bonuses to Lincoln employees who
sold junk bonds in ACC in place of in
place of CDs also all of these people
you know 23,000 of them to the tune of
225 million dollars 23,000 people when
it displayed Savings and Loan thought
they were buying insured CDs they
brought their life savings in
they one guy retired it was 65 years old
he brought in sixty five thousand one
thousand dollars for every year of his
life he'd been saving
they bought a CD that he brought was
insured and what he got was a junk bond
of a CC 225 million dollars in one case
this is incredible that means like a
b-movie they had testimony before
Gonzalez's committee in Congress uh in
one case a blind Widow got thirty
thousand dollars from her husband's a
life insurance policy she called up
Lincoln Savings and Loan and this nice
young man offered to come to her house
and pick her up and bring her to the
bank because she was blind when they got
to the bank he had to read her the
contract because she was planning and he
left out the fine print okay
now her money's gone it's gone she may
never see it you know as part of the
bankruptcy they're supposed to figure
out ways to pay it off but I mean that
money is gone okay so that's what
Keating did now you know he said well
it's business you know losses did he
profit well from 86 to 88 Keating and
his family took it's known that he took
thirty four million dollars out of SCC
when he declared bankruptcy he took a
salary 90 percent salary cut was
generous of him he went from 5 million
to $500,000 she's still being paid five
hundred thousand dollars a year to run
that country are they good to to operate
that bankrupt company company huh it's
known that ACC had a subsidiary oh I
know it's incredible Frank ACC had a
subsidiary in Panama the famous money
laundering Center and all of course all
those records are secret nobody knows
how much money passed through that
company but interestingly enough as part
of the bankruptcy proceedings
a creditor came out of the woodwork
Credit Suisse all largest
Bank came forth with a bill to Keating
in Lincoln Savings and Loan for twenty
four million dollars in consulting fees
now I don't know how much money was
behind that consultation but that was
twenty four million in consulting fees
so you can imagine what Credit Suisse
was doing for mr. Charles Keating didn't
let the bank that created such a scandal
in in Switzerland where they found that
it was laundering a lot of drug money
and the head person in in Switzerland
who was a cousin of big political here
in the United States she was involved in
it as well Credit Suisse yeah and so uh
yeah and so you know they're all
interconnected it's gone yeah so there
was drug money involved with that Bank
so it and also the fact that they were
in Panama were so many so much drug
money is laundered as well is it the
point is that it's money laundering you
know whether it comes from Charles
Keating or whether it comes from the
mid-eighteen cartel yeah it's his money
that's got to be cleaned whether it
comes from a defense contractor or you
know I see and so now one other thing
you should know about Charles Keating is
all this time he was funding anti-porn
campaigns and cities all around the
country and he's a founding member and
the chief contributor in an organization
called citizens for decency through law
Charles giving a paragon of virtue well
now he was he's been indicted and all
kinds of stuff has me there's been a
civil suit against him he's in court
right now because he's suing the
government for taking over Lincoln
savings alone yeah he's mad
they took his bank away from it
so have you sued the government and
that's that's where the testimony from
the accountants came from
that's the money in that trial now is
heating just an example of stuff like
this that was going on everywhere or is
he unusual no no he's the he's the
classic example the one regulator called
him the worst of the worst he's but he
represents a pattern with deregulation
the the banks were allowed to put their
money anywhere and all of the all of the
deposits were insured so there was no
risk to them whatsoever
I mean it's um and and in some cases
borrowers were told they didn't have to
pay the money back it was on short just
take it there were kickback scams there
was there were there were conspiracies
all over the country little groups of
SNL's here and there we get together the
reason they would get together is is to
hide these losses on their books and in
fact it was so common there was a whole
vocabulary that grew up around the
accounting tricks to keep the examiners
off their off their backs there was
there were daisy chains where a group of
SNL's would pass bad assets from one to
the other keeping them ahead of the
examiner so the examiners are coming in
we'd sell off our bad loans to you the
examiners leave you sell them back the
examiner goes to you everything's fine
we just there were things called land
flips where the same piece of land was
sold several times in quick succession
each time at a much higher value
property values were inflated for
example in one case 900 percent in a
week there were things called trading a
dead horse for a dead cow swapping bad
assets junk bonds were very important
here there were
a couple of circles of SNL's who worked
with Milken and they would sell junk
bonds one to the other and that did a
couple things it would make them look
profitable on the books and it would
also keep the value of those bonds high
because they were being traded so all of
these things were going on to hide the
extent of the losses for two reasons one
is that the owners were getting rich and
the other is that the industry as a
whole didn't want the news out that they
were losing so much money there's one
other aspect which we don't have time to
go into in great detail but as surfaced
recently as a result of a Houston Post
article and that is that it looks like
the CIA and the Mafia were big and a
failure a lot of these SNL's you've been
doing some research into that you're
still continuing your analysis of it but
can you give us a feel for what you
found well this this aspect of the
scandal as you said was written up by
the series of articles in the Houston
post by one reporter guy named Pete
Bruton and he was looking into the
failure of a few savings and loans and
he noticed some mafia connected names
showing up and some CIA connected names
showing up and in fact of their I have
been so far 23 failed savings and loans
whose failures so were directly
connected to losses that were associated
with mafia people and or CIA people in
some cases the Mafia and the CIA had
worked together Rob they've been doing
this for years so do you see any
familiar names that have been
participating in other CIA activities
over the years sure all the
all of the renegade CIA agents that were
involved in the Bay of Pigs iran-contra
Watergate Frank Castro for example was
in jail in 1984 for smuggling marijuana
and he was released to train some
Contras and in the meantime he was
involved with the Savings and Loan in
Florida sunshine bank which was bought
with the drug money and a known CIA
agent was the front the there's a web an
intricate network that Pete Bruton at
the Houston post has exposed that
connects this group of people the ex CIA
people with some some of the Savings and
Loan scandalous names the Mafia's
involved who are some of the more CIA
people that well one of the major deals
was done in South Florida a company
called st. Joe's paper company sold lots
of land expensive Gulf Coast land to a
gentleman named Lawrence Freeman who was
fronting for a guy named Pattinson
now James Atchison is a known arms
dealer he's had several companies that
have been CIA fronts in this particular
deal and this is the sort of the
centerpiece of Britain's work a hundred
and twenty million dollars disappeared
seven million of it was sent to a
money-laundering center on the Isle of
Jersey which is also used by
drug dealers in fact Lawrence Freeman
who set up the deal originally pled
guilty to charges of money laundering
for a gentleman named Santo Trafficante
who's the head mafioso in Florida and
the cia's had relationships with him
well exactly that's the whole point
names like the Freeman was very close
with the gentleman named Helliwell who
was one of the founders of the CIA with
back in the days of Bill Donovan of the
OSS and of course William Casey was
involved in all of these things exactly
I mean it's just a astounding of in
addition through again an intricate
network of deals from one Savings and
Loan to another
Silverado Savings and Loan in Denver
it's a name that keeps popping up yeah
it was also on a daisy chain to keep
junk bonds afloat and sham profits all
those accounting tricks we were talking
about wasn't that one that George Bush's
son won Georgia was unsocial son is on
the board of directors so I was on board
of directors during the time all this
was going on so I mean it would take at
least one and maybe several programs to
detail all of these connections but it's
it's pretty it seems pretty clear and
Bruton has done a lot of work and he's
documented these things quite carefully
what are your final thoughts about all
this in conclusion well the savings and
loan crisis is just that it's a an
absolute crisis and it's a crisis of
public trust this this is there's a bit
of betrayal of the American people that
at every level of government
putting our financial institutions and
it's going to change America we will
know this country will never be the same
if there's one thing that comes out of
this it should be and I hope the
American people will wake up and do this
it should be a critical examination of
who we are and what we are as a nation
we have to find the structural flaws in
our government that allowed this to
happen and we've got to find the moral
flaws in our national character that
allowed this to happen and if we don't
make some changes in some pretty
creative changes and pretty soon I'm
afraid that this noble experiment and
democracy is is over